hello everyone
uh good evening um my name is priyana
trajan i'm an astrophysicist
and on the faculty at yale in the
departments of astronomy
and physics i happen to serve as the
current director of the frankie program
in science and the humanities
and i'm really excited to invite you to
this evening's talk the title of our
talk is mozart
starling a story of art language
and the human relationship with the
natural world
before we start i would first like to
say thanks to
richard and barbara frankie for their
generous support
of this program as well as many other
initiatives
at yale and i would also like to
give a thank you to the connecticut
parrot society and the mozart society of
america
for spreading the word uh about today's
talk
um and um you know opening up this
opportunity
um for everyone to listen to
leander's wonderful talk uh that i'm
eagerly
um waiting to hear and
um to introduce
leander and um to
um to talk about
uh birding in general we have
our local international
expert evolutionary ornithologist
professor rick prum who incidentally was
the
inaugural and previous director of the
frankie program
rick as many of you know rick prom
for those of you who might have read his
wonderful books
has done research on diverse topics
including you know avian phylogenetics
behavior revolution
uh evolution of aesthetics or and
most of all he is an avid birder so
i would like to turn over hosting
today's event
to rick and uh rick welcome and thank
you so much
thank you and a pleasure to uh to be
here uh today visiting with
the frankie program in our new uh for
our
a custom zoom state uh uh
first uh uh thanks again to rich and
barbara frankie uh
and great to see them here today it's my
pleasure to introduce
the speaker today uh land hout is
an award-winning author naturalist and
eco-philosopher
whose writing in multiple books has
connected
nature and biodiversity to the lives of
everyday lives of people um uh
her previous books include the urban
bestiary being
the encountering of everyday wife uh
everyday
life in the wild uh crown crow planet
essential wisdom for the urban
wilderness uh and
pilgrim of the great bird continent
importance of
everything and other lessons from
darwin's notebooks all published by
little brown
uh in the next month she has a new book
coming out
rooted life at the crossroads of science
nature and spirit
with little brown and today we had the
pleasure of hearing
uh from her on her award-winning book in
2017
mozart starling uh so uh thank you and
welcome to the frankie program
uh lyanna thank you so much
i'm delighted to be here i want to begin
with some gratitude
thank you to the frankies for your
generosity i am so happy to be
part of this beautiful series um thank
you professor notre john i'm sure i said
your name incorrectly
and uh thank you professor prem for that
lovely introduction and thank you to
professor ty camp
for arranging this we had so many emails
back and forth
um figuring out how things would go and
who else should i thank i know
who frederick professor camp's son
frederick i hear started this whole
adventure with a thoughtful
holiday gift so well done frederick
thank you
so much i i
forgot to thank carmen for today's vlog
as well to be featured so i wanted to
say thank you
to both you a wonderful speaker and
our participant active participant
hopefully carmen
who will be there and um i also wanted
to give a shout out because
uh to rick's book uh which is this
one of my absolute favorite books as
well
so i think for all of you um without
further ado
uh leander please one further delay if i
may i'm sorry i was remiss i should have
mentioned
uh please put your questions during the
talk in the chat
and we'll monitor the chat and at the
end of the day we'll get to as many of
those questions as we can
so thank you uh and uh now uh
onward okay yes ask me anything all
right i'm gonna pop the share screen on
wish that we were in person together of
course it's
wonderful to be so but i one of the
things that this
platform gives us the opportunity to do
is to gather
from places all over the place and so i
wanted to share briefly that i am
uh speaking to you from seattle in the
pacific northwest
we are surrounded by the cascade
mountains and the olympic mountains
and this is really a land of
mountains and rivers without and lots of
ferns and mosses and just down the road
from my house is a wooded forested path
to the salish sea and so i want to say
at this point that i live
and work on the unseated lands of the
duwamish tribe
and the coast salish peoples and i
acknowledge with honor and so much
gratitude
this land and the people who have lived
here from time immemorial
if you can see i'm gonna kind of pop
this up because we've got a bird coming
through
um i'm kind of laughing because the
title
of this lecture series is the
distinguished speaker series
and yet i am coming to you from my
kitchen
with a starling on my head and pandemic
hair
and i'm feeling that the whole kitchen
situation is
very undistinguished and i promise you
that upstairs in my study
there's lots of books high distinguished
level
uh but the reason that we're here is
that
ty camp and i were talking before this
series about whether or not carmen could
join for the q a
afterwards and i said you know she's
welcome to join the talk and that would
be fun but
she has a mind of her own and there's no
guaranteeing that if we just open the
door of her aviary
for the q a that she'll come out then so
i decided we decided together to just
have the door of her aviary open it's
really close by here this is her
uh most comfortable room so she might be
flying in and out
and i think we might just be a little
bit light on our feet and i might talk
about
um starling natural history not
necessarily in the order that i planned
it
just so that we can take advantage of
having the bird here
so um i usually start by
doing a little poll and i'm not gonna do
the zoom pole i just would like you all
to humor me and from wherever you are if
you are a person
who feels that you could with maybe 95
accuracy identify as starling when you
see one
please raise your hand
okay lots
lots of hands and not not all the hands
just as to be expected
so i will tell you that if you did raise
your hand you are
really in the upper just few percent
strata of people in this country
most people do not know um
if they know anything about birds at all
they what they know about starlings is
that we are supposed to dislike them
but very few people can identify them
many people think that they are crows
baby crows conflating smallness with
babiness as uh people often do
or black birds generally i was speaking
with a very
illustrious uh person in the opera world
when i was researching this book
and he we were sitting at a coffee shop
in seattle
where he has lived for two decades and
we're
he knew about that mozart had a starling
and we were talking
a lot about that and he finally came to
a point in the conversation
where he leaned over and he said but you
know i've never seen a starling
and i thought oh my goodness so i said
you know
let's maestro just lean over this way
into the um to the uh
and look at the wire above that above
the coffee shop and there are
four starlings sitting there and you
just laugh i said you're walking under
him every single day of your life
a question that i'm often asked is why i
wrote this book
and it's a it's a question that every
author
gets and um it's
most it's more fitting for me with this
book because i am an ecologically minded
person i'm a nature writer
i'm a student of birdlife and if there's
one thing that people know
about starlings is that they are the
most despised
bird in north america for people that
know anything about conservation
and ornithology and that's with good
reason
they cause 800 million dollars of
agricultural damage every year
they are a um a non-native species and
an
invasive species so they have grown in
from when they were introduced here in
1890 from a population of just 80 birds
to the 200 million starlings that now
blanket north america and their main
ecological
issue is that they compete with um
native
cavity nesters for that rare resource of
cavity nests so small birds like
chickadees certain woodpeckers
bluebirds and things like that so um
people say why would i of all people
write a book about starlings and it's
something that i never
thought i would do i had already um i
apologize that the starling is
fluttering through my already bad
pandemic hair
so it's kind of a
funny situation it's okay carmen
um so
one day i was working on a completely
different book at my desk and i looked
out the window at the parking strip
and what i saw was about it was autumn
so the family groups of summer were
starting to break down
and gather into the larger um flocks
that characterize the huge gatherings of
starlings
in autumn and into the winter and
i was looking out there and i thought
dang it there's 30 starlings they're
scaring away
the cute little chickadees that i would
rather have out there so
i pounded on the window and the birds i
had a teenager at the time so i
recognized the look that they gave me it
was
just it was complete and different they
kind of looked up at me like
yeah we don't care what you think and so
i pounded harder
and this time the stylings lifted from
the grass and they
turned into the light and then of course
they they didn't actually leave they
went back onto the sidewalk and um but
in that moment
the light captured that beautiful
iridescence of
their feathers and i thought you know
i might dislike starlings but dang they
are so
so pretty and then i noticed it seemed
kind of serendipitous that at the same
time
uh spotify was on and mozart's prague
symphony was playing and i didn't know
at the time that that was a symphony
that he composed during the time that he
lived with the starling
uh but i did sort of have that sense of
things coming together
and i remembered in that moment
the story that i'd heard over and over
again and even had written about
just briefly in earlier books that
mozart had a pet starling
and i sat there contemplating that kind
of dissonance
you know that here in um
here is this composer that we consider
to be
one of the most sublime voices
in the western classical canon and he
had as a muse and a companion
this most despised of birds and i should
point out that
that in europe where mozart is from um
starlings are native birds and so they
don't have the reputation that they have
here um
so i sat there kind of dwelling in that
complicated dissonance and i just went
down the rabbit hole
of exploring the story and the thing
that i had to start with was
you know was it even true because there
are so many apocryphal stories
about composers there's that idea that
beethoven cut the legs off of his piano
because he was deaf and he could sit on
the floor and hear
the um the tremblings
of movement or vibrations of the piano
while he played and that is very very
likely an untrue story and i thought
gosh maybe i've been misled by this
mozart starling story
but it turns out that it is true did a
little research
and found out that this is pretty much
the way it went
in april of 1784 mozart was living in
vienna
and he just
finished a new concerto it was the
beautiful
concerto in g major and he was not very
good at keeping records but one thing
that he did keep really good
track of was his finished music so he
wrote in his
you know in his um composition diary
that he had completed this concerto it
was k
453 the 453rd
finished piece that he had written at
age 24
makes me feel kind of lazy and there
were hundreds of others of you know
smaller lesser compositions that he
didn't think
worthy of making it into the diary so
anyway april 1784
wrote the concerto he had a fair copy of
it
made to send to his father leopold the
great violinist and violin pedagogue
who was living in salisbury about 250
um miles away so by kind of rough
carriage road
so he had that sent to his father along
with a letter that said you know father
i would love
your opinion about this he always valued
leopold's good opinion
uh but he said please be very careful
with it don't let it
don't let anyone see it mozart was
always a little bit paranoid that his
work
was going to be stolen or copied or
imitated
by a lesser composer and not without
reason this happened sometimes
so this is all in april send it to his
father and in may he got confirmation
that leopold in salzburg had received it
this composition
was slated to be performed in june in
vienna
so april is finished june it's going to
be
performed in the middle in may
may 26 of 1784. mozart went
into a bird shop and he lived in the
graben area
of uh that kind of fashionable shopping
district
of vienna then and now and so he went
downst
downstairs from his apartments and he
was walking the street he walked into a
bird vendor's shop
and he bought a sparling for three
creature
and the starling was singing the motif
from the concerto from the allegrato
movement of the concerto in g
so we know this
because although i said that mozart was
a terrible record keeper
he did for a while keep a small expense
notebook
where he wrote down everything that he
ever bought
and it's kind of funny i it's anomalous
because it wasn't something that he
would normally do he was married to
constanza
weber mozart um mozart
who um was very good at home economics
she had to be
because their economic uh finances were
in such disarray so in my imagination
it was her constanza that gave the
notebook to mozart with the admonition
you know honey
i want you to write down every single
thing that you buy every day
and then show it to me at the end of the
week and we'll talk
so mozart was really good about that and
he wrote down three crits are for the
bird
and right underneath it he wrote down
what he heard so this was mozart
a couple of years before this this is
mozart at about 22 years old
he was 24 when he got the bird
and this is what he heard so
what this slide says if you're not
musical don't worry
um but it shows the line of the motif
that the starling was singing
and it shows it the way that mozart
wrote it
and then the way the starling sang it so
the starling made a couple of changes
if you're not musical don't worry um but
the
there's this little um arch with
the dot under it that's a fermata a long
pause
and then you'll also see that the bird
sharped
the g's which sounds absolutely terrible
but it's exactly the sort of thing that
a starling would do
so i'm going to play this for you and
this is just me plunking it
on the piano in the living room um
and if you listen carefully you'll be
able to hear
carmen from way over here in the
kind of the mud room where her aviary is
singing
in the background
so listen for the changes listen
carefully to the first
line this darling does not sing the
grace notes um
but there you go
[Music]
i hope you could hear carmen in the
background there um
so a lot of most people most biographers
of mozart do not mention the starling at
all because it takes some sleuthing
to get to the bottom of the story you
have to look at diaries notebooks
letters from visitors and from mozart
himself
and other ephemera but when people do
mention this darling and there's a lot
of misinformation about what the
starling could sing and what the
starling couldn't sing
um when they come to the idea that
mozart
heard the starling mimicking his motif
that he must have been furious so
starlings are gifted
mimics so it wasn't really strange that
a starling could do this and i will talk
about
that more about that in a little bit um
people thought he must have been furious
because he really was paranoid
that that people were going to copy and
imitate his music and here somehow
it had gotten in the world enough that a
bird the starling a good nimit could
learn
to mimic it but the information
that we have from mozart himself in the
little notebook that he kept
was the record that he bought the bird
these two lines that he copied and we
have
mozart had absolutely perfect pitch so
we know that his
version of this darling song was exactly
right
and then underneath that instead of some
exclamation of fury
he wrote and i forgive me i do not speak
german
but the line is das vas
that was wonderful
so
so we have the real carmen here and you
guys will have to tell me since i can't
see myself
how um if i'm situated well enough that
you guys can
y'all can see her is this all right yeah
fun okay good so as you can see um
carmen looks a little bit different than
the young bird she was in that
photograph
and one of the questions that people
often ask
is how they think that
i talk about this wonderful mystery of
mozart coming to have the starling
and it's a multi-layered mystery and one
of the questions
um that people ask me most is how did a
starling
learn to sing this motif
and how is really not that much of a
mystery starlings are
gifted mimics and in this country
especially in north america where
starlings are so despised
people bother to learn very little about
them
but they are better mimics than the
corvids
the crows and jays and ravens and they
are on par
with some parrots so it depends on the
starling and it depends on the parrot
but um they're very capable mimics and
they mimic environmental
sounds other birds animals
music and the human voice and many other
things
so the real issue
is when the starling learned
mozart's concerto because as i said he
finished it in april it wasn't supposed
to be out until june
so we don't know if mozart visited the
shop
and taught the bird
the motif himself when he was whistling
along as he often did
or whether you know he heard mozart
practicing out the window
and from his apartments above or there
are all kinds of other possibilities of
the way that
the starling could have learned it and
in most whenever
you know you'll read about this in
program notes
when you go to the symphony and hear
this concerto perform
and i am absolutely shocked at how often
the course of events described are
absolutely impossible
or people will say learned people will
say in program notes that
the starling could sing the whole
concerto which even for a starling is
too much
or that the sterling sang a couple of
notes flat
which you know no respectable starling
would sing flat
so um one of the things that i enjoyed
doing was all the research that it
really came to narrow down the
possibilities of what could have
actually happened
um so
i really went down the rabbit hole of
exploring the relationship with mozart
and his startling i
read every scientific paper that i could
find
in any language that i could read which
is english
so um i've read all of the scientific
literature i put my binoculars
around my neck and went out into the
urban wilds and studied
uh starlings extensively in the field i
traveled
to vienna and spent um days in the
apartments
where mozart lived with his starling to
kind of imagine how their life
would have gone together there and i
realized that
there was one thing that was missing in
all of this research that
i really needed to do in order to
understand how mozart live was with a
starling
and that was to take a drastic step
and live with a starling myself
so let me first say
that it is absolutely illegal to
harm touch even glance sideways
at any nest nestlings or most birds in
north america so it is completely
illegal to
have a nestling bird of most kinds most
birds are protected by the migratory
bird treaty act
starlings are an exception in being
a non-native bird and an invasive bird
they are not protected by the treaty act
or
fish and wildlife and we are not only
allowed but actually encouraged by
federal and local fish and wildlife
departments to remove starling nests
and eggs and even nestlings in any way
that we can
so i personally agree that we should
find ways to
limit startling nests and eggs but i
personally ethically believe that after
the nestlings are hatched is not the
time to
remove the nestlings i did however learn
when i was on
on the hunt for a starling for my
research
that um there was a nest in a seattle
park
not far from my home that was going to
be removed by the fish and wildlife or
the um
state city parks department
and i had an insider in the parks who
knew
the research that i was working on and
he told me about it and i said you know
those starlings have actually hatched
already because i've been studying all
the starlings in the area and he said
well you know
no one cares they're just starlings so
he said it's gonna happen tonight
you don't have that much time so um as
with a lot of so-called wildlife control
um when animals are removed by
wildlife or killed by wildlife
fish and wildlife organizations or city
parks department they do it at night so
that people
don't get upset so
i told my husband that it was our one
chance to get a starling and
he was a little bit dubious about it but
we went up to the park it was a
harrowing adventure that involved us
sneaking into this boy's bathroom at a
park
borrowing the park's garbage can
climbing on top of it
starlings are cavity nesters and they
like to nest far enough back
that a raccoon's paw cannot reach them
and in this case
the starlings were way way back in the
eaves of
this kind of slightly open-air bathroom
so i climbed up there and
i couldn't reach and my husband climbed
up there with his long arm
and he could just we could feel the heat
of the starling nestlings but we
couldn't quite reach them and finally
with me sort of leaning on this garbage
can against the wall to keep it from
falling out from
under my poor husband so he wouldn't end
up just dangling by his arm from this
bat boy's bathroom ceiling um finally
he grasped a sterling chick and he
dropped it in my hands
and the chick was only a few days old
and i looked at
this little bird and i thought oh my
goodness this bird
is so sickly she was wheezing she had
ectoparasites that i could
literally see crawling all over her and
she just didn't see it she seemed highly
ephemeral
and i said honey you know it would be
better if we had two they could keep
each other warm
and the glare i got from my husband in
that moment
with him standing there with his bruised
arm was just
it was priceless but it also told me
that we were going to have just the ones
darling carmen
so um
what i didn't realize is that
i have a background in rehabilitation of
birds especially raptors but at the
raptor center in vermont people would
bring in all kinds of birds and so
i'd raised starlings before and many
other young birds but
um i didn't realize that
raising one just from a few days to
adulthood would take over my life
and this is a video and we were testing
it before and we
found out that it's just not it's not
playing very well it's a little bit
glitchy
but this is how she looked uh from
my writing desk so i would sit every day
writing this book mozart's starling my
laptop is in the middle of
my desk to the right was this little
tiny tupperware
with this kind of frightful getting
uglier by the day
your baby starling and hungrier as well
who needed feeding every
20 minutes from dawn to dusk and on the
other side
of my computer there was often delilah
the cat and it was really funny delilah
knew that she wasn't supposed to
eat the bird but she would ever
so slightly reach over with her paw
and i'd say delilah nope pull it back
and just pretend to be licking herself
um and i'm just gonna
put this on just for a second and see if
you can get a sense of it and i'm not
gonna leave it on for the whole time
because i know it's not really gonna
work but i'm just gonna
keep my fingers crossed and see if you
can get a little bit of a vibe
from my end
so i'm sorry if that didn't look good
for you but it's um
just a kind of a fun little image of the
cheaping bird that
was um my constant company
what was really funny about this and
what i didn't expect was how
limiting this would be to my um
movement i had to be i did have to feed
her
every 20 minutes and keep her a certain
temperature i
basically couldn't leave the house if i
went for a walk and i was
back it took me you know 22 minutes
instead of 20. i would
walk inside and i would hear this
incredible
um touring sound there's this very loud
touring sound that young starlings make
they outgrow it
in a couple of months but that would it
would just be
pouring over the whole house and i would
brush up to feed her
and one time i thought you know i'm
tired of being stranded and i need
groceries and so
i packed up in her box i packed her up
with the food
and i just went to the nearest grocery
store and by the time i got there
she was so cold because she needs to be
about 85 degrees i had a lamp for her at
home
and so what i had to do is i literally
took her and put her
in my bra ran in
got my milk and bread came out again and
thought all right
i'm never doing this again
and you can see this little stirring
stick
here i in the um in the slide one of the
things
that's interesting about keeping a baby
startling is that although we
are allowed to do anything that we want
to starlings
kill and maim them we are not legally
allowed
to take them home and raise them in our
living rooms they don't want people
having
pet starlings that they might propagate
so
i was already a minor felon in terms of
taking the bird but then i went ran into
starbucks and stole a whole handful of
those little stirring sticks
to feed her with so my rap sheet was
just getting really long at this point
and even though she was so sickly
amusing with a lot of care
carmen grew very fat she did get uglier
before she got cuter
we couldn't tell for certain whether she
was a male or female at this point
um so we chose the name carmen which
could be used for males or females i
love this
juvenile plumage they have this very
white chin that allows them to be
found from below which we discovered
when carmen flew out the kitchen window
one day and she got lost and we found
her high high in a fur tree outside our
home
partly by the contact call that she was
making but partly by the whiteness of
her chin
so this is a little kind of family photo
album
quickly carmen became
so at home among us and i don't know if
she thinks that we are starlings or
that she's and we're part of her vlog or
she's part of our human family
um either way she is very much at home
and so
this is kind of a little album of how
things look at home
this is a look at a plumage that we
rarely see because the
birds only keep it for a couple of weeks
and it's a time when they are cared for
and still
pretty hidden by their parents so i like
throwing this in for bird people
claire my daughter is reading jane eyre
and carmen loved to sit on her shoulder
and kind of snuggle under her hair while
she was reading
and here she is all grown into her
beautiful
teenage juvenile plumage so this is what
it looked like and what it often looks
like for me
to be researching or writing on any
given day carmen
does like to be up um up with me and
the reason that i i didn't take her up
into my study today is that sometimes
she decides all of a sudden that she's
anxious up there and wants to leave and
i didn't want to
interrupt our talk um but as you can see
i i'm just noticing in this
photo there's a lot of books reflected
in the win and the um window
so you can see that it actually is very
distinguished up there
anyway carmen would sit on my shoulder
and she makes
every single task i do take twice as
long as it normally would
um she she
steals my post-its she gets into all
kinds of trouble
she sits on my hands while i'm trying to
type and
just creates all kind of a ruckus but
does like to be with me no matter what
i'm doing
she sends messages that i'm not ready to
send she likes
facebook posts that i do not like um
it's been a little bit of a problem but
all of that i think looks really kind of
tranquil
like it's fun having a starling around
and it is but
what it doesn't show is the background
symphony of starling sound that
we live with in our home so i
i hope that this works i want to talk a
little bit about what you're going to
hear
um
so in this video carmen has two
different kinds of vocalizations
one is um the array
of starling just typical starling
vocalizations
and for people who are interested in
birds and ornithology it
starlings are a songbird and it is
typical for most species
that the male of the species is the
singer and sings the
i mean males and females both have many
vocalizations but it's the male that
typically
sings the species what is recognized as
the species song
in the breeding season for many reasons
in part to attract attractimate
to create and defend a territory and
other things
um for a few birds and starlings are
among them
females also sing so male and female
starlings
sing year round they don't just use
their like chatty
vocalizations they use actual song
year-round
it becomes more uh frequent
and more animated for male birds at
during the breeding season and it is
also during the breeding season
that female starlings fall absolutely
silent
on their nests the first time this
happened was with carmen i thought that
she was depressed or that there was i i
was doing something wrong
but i've learned that she does it
seasonally and um
so it is little wonder that it was only
recently i mean it was a little bit over
10 years ago
that we finally figured out that female
starlings also sing
so in this little clip you'll hear
startling vocalizations but mixed in
you'll hear
some of that mimicry that characterizes
the
talents the mimicry talents of the
starling
um what's in here
so you're gonna hear because it's a
little it's all a little bit wisely but
you'll hear
the whir of the coffee grinder you'll
hear the creak of our oak floor
once carmen carmen learns new sounds all
of the time even though she's
almost seven years old starlings again
this is different for starlings from
other songbirds most songbirds usually
use learn their species song
and other vocalizations within the first
year or so of their life
um and then that's it but starlings like
some other mimics are lifelong learners
so they will actually
mimic novel sounds and continue learning
throughout their lives
and karma's working on a new sound now
i'm trying to figure out what it is
and this happens a lot if she's not
imitating or mimicking a book a human
vocalization or a piece of music
it'll be some environmental sound and i
cannot figure it out
and so one of those was the sun where
the center should go
and i thought what is going on and
finally i stepped outside
um just over the threshold of where she
usually hangs out and i stepped on our
old
wood oak floor and it creeped in just
that same way
i thought she's just mimicking the place
that i stepped every day
also in here in quick succession you'll
hear a meow
a high honey and a kissy sound like
that's that you used to call animals
and also a khmer honey so i'll play it i
hope that you'll be able to hear it
and i'll kind of point out the sounds as
they come
that was coffee grinder
for
clement is responding to that
so i hope people could hear that okay
so um
carmen uses her mimicry in three
different ways
that i have noticed one of them is
that she just mixes it in like she did
here so she's making a lot of typical
starling noises
and she throws her some of her favorite
mimic sounds
inside she also does it randomly
so i will be sitting in the living room
by myself say and she'll be in her
aviary because she goes into her aviary
for the evening
we like to leave it open so she can get
as much freedom of flight as possible
but in the evening she starts sort of
bunking around so
we make sure she's safe inside when dusk
falls
but i will be in the living room and
i'll hear her say just
from the next room come here honey
and i'll sit there going am i supposed
to
go there it's just sort of it's
a little bit haunting and kind of super
interesting
um but the other way is participatory
and i'm sorry i don't have this slide
for you
it was a um i don't know what happened
but i'll at least tell you the story
so every morning when i come downstairs
i'm usually the first one awake
i'll come downstairs and carmen will
look at me and the first thing that
she'll say
in this hushed whispered voice is hi
carmen because that's what she usually
hears
when i come down the stairs first thing
and then our
big cat delilah will come down the
stairs and carmen will look at delilah
and before delilah says anything carmen
says
and then when i go and i pick up the jar
of coffee beans to make the coffee
but before i start the coffee grinder
she says
and then and this is the video i hope to
show you um when i open and close the
door of the microwave but before i press
the buttons
she'll say beep beep beep and it is
pitch perfect like we literally can not
tell them apart we cannot tell a
microwave from carmen
and so it took me months of living with
a starling who had this wonderful
oral attunement to recognize something
that is
little understood and little studied or
discussed in the literature and that is
that carmen
starling vocalizations now i have no
idea what's going on with my hair
after all that startling visitation
um
starling's aural
involvement with their environment
is not only participatory but it is
anticipatory so she is
always in the world waiting
hourly attuned to what is going on and
ready to participate
by proclaiming the sound that is about
to happen
and this is i just think the most
magnificent knowledge it took me so long
to figure it out
and then to realize you know my first
thought was wow i have a really
smart starling in my house but of course
it's not just this starling
it is a capacity of all starlings to
live with this wild aural attunement
and so when i step through the door it
makes me realize just
from learning from this little bird
makes me realize that we live
within this infinity of consciousness
conscience consciousness
okay i'm not even consciousnesses
there we go an infinity of intelligences
that is beyond our knowing and even our
imagining
and it makes the world seem so full of
wonder i think of emerson's quote
we lie in the lap of an immense
intelligence
and so um
it's you know i i just think it's one of
the most wonderful things i've learned
from living with the starling and when i
think about it
i know that we have ecological issues
with the starling but i think you know
this what we are learning from their
song and their vocalizations
is so magnificent what could be wrong
i don't know if you can see i can't see
myself
enter noam chomsky
shout out to steve harrington who
has a company in portland called
just say gnome he read my book and he
learned that i borrowed the statue of
garden gnome chomsky from a friend
and he sent me my own so
very happy so
back in the 1950s this very bright young
linguist
noam chomsky was hanging out at mit
thinking a lot about what makes human
language unique
and you have to remember that in the 50s
behaviorism was very popular and b.f
skinner had
the prominent theory about
how children learn language and he felt
that it was
through rewards so you know if a kid
says something right the mom
give him a pat on the head or a cupcake
or something and they get all of this
positive reinforcement
and noam chomsky thought and rightly
that that was nonsense
he came up over years with a very
different idea that we have a rule-based
innate rule-based way of
coming to apprehend and utilize language
he called it universal grammar
and one of the most important aspects of
this universal grammar
or rules was a certain kind of syntax
so as humans there's two different ways
that we add
information and complexity to our
sentences one of them
is by um just
adding on to it adding on to the end of
the sentence right
so say we have a sentence like mozart
played the violin
we could add to it by saying mozart
violin and had a pet bird
mozart played the violin and had a pet
bird who liked to sit on his shoulder
and we could keep doing that forever and
for some weird reason the metaphor that
i used in the book was like a rat
growing a longer tail
and for some other weird reason i didn't
edit it out
i still use that metaphor so the rat's
tail is growing longer and longer
adding onto it by brick track by check
but the other way that humans
complexify our sentences is from the
inside out
through a syntactical device called
recursion
so when we say instead of saying
mozart played the violin
and had a pet starling we could say
mozart who played the violin had a pet
starling
mozart who played the violin and enjoyed
singing
had a pet starling and we could grow
that sentence from within
over and over again forever so instead
of being like the rat with the tail it's
our sentences become like peonies these
layered
blossoming from within and we see
recursion sometimes in
music as well including the music of
mozart
but this became very important for noam
chomsky
who decided that it was
it was a cornerstone of his universal
grammar
that all humans
and only humans recognize
recursive recursivity
in the way that we use our language so
anthropologists are actually busy
debunking the first part of that that
all humans recognize
um recursion but the really interesting
thing is that starlings are the first
animal
to prove the second part of chomsky's
theory incorrect
so there is a um neuropsychologist tim
gentner
at the university um uc san diego
and he did some studies where he took
startling sounding voices and
little bits of them and he made them
into patterns he made them into linear
patterns like a a b b and then he made
them into
recursive patterns where he'd stick a
different pattern
in the middle of this linear pattern and
what he found was that all though it
took some doing it took
many of the starlings thousands of of
tries listening
that they could ultimately recognize
recursive patterns
so when noam chomsky
heard this research he was furious
he woke from his dogmatic slumbers and
he rushed to critique the study
and he denounced the starlings behavior
as being nothing more than
memorizing or counting rattles he said
that was basically like party tricks
and actually the things that he was
suggesting the sterlings were doing were
very complex behaviors for a bird like a
starling but he was unwilling to
entertain the idea that um they were
recognizing recursion
and so later tim gentner took
great pains to make his studies more
complexified
and make the patterns more difficult so
that there was really
no way to claim that the starlinks were
just acting from memory
or counting so um
yeah you really have to side with the
starling science on that
which is quite fascinating so
linguistics were
one of the ways one of the main ways
that i ended up
to my surprise i didn't expect to go
down the path of linguistics by the way
i found myself on the screen here so
thank you um
it's the way that we're arranged um
did not expect to go down the path of
linguistics and we can talk more about
that if you want to in the q a there's
just so much fun stuff there
about the anthropological dimension as
well i did expect
to go in to music and
one of the things that surprised me was
i discovered the work
of a very well-known neurophysicist and
she said
the most remarkable thing she said i
want to get the quote right right
that only humans have the capacity
to engage with music only humans have
the capacity to engage with music
and i read that aloud at our dinner
table one night and everyone just
cracked up because
we live with this darling who is who
cannot
we cannot have music going on in the
house without her reacting
wildly um
i had this great fantasy
when carmen came to the house i didn't
um
i didn't want to teach her any
particular vocalization i just wanted to
see
how her mimicry and vocal learning would
unfold in the
uh general household round of our daily
life
but i did have one exception and that is
that
i'm so sorry i was just making sure
she's not dating the cat water which is
bad for her um she's bathing in some
other water that she's not allowed to be
in but it is
it's safe at least so
the exception was that i was hoping she
would learn
to sing or mimic the
um the line that mozart's darling saying
that from his allegretto from the
concerto and g major
so i put it on loop on
my phone and i played it for her over
and over again while she was growing up
and
she had no interest whatsoever and here
i'm thinking it would be you know the
perfect conclusion to the book and she'd
be famous
and oprah would come but she just
doesn't give it a glance
but other music she leaps to life
like an opera hero when she hears it and
she doesn't like much of mozart at all
she does like uh the theme of papageno
this very bird-like
character from the magic flute that
i believe to be inspired in some part by
mozart's time with this starling
she also likes uh one of his uh
divertables a musical joke
that he wrote during the time that she
lived with or that his
sterling lived with him as well and the
famous oran ornithologist baptista
and an ethologist meredith west sort of
over
um played the musical joke
over lane with the starling
vocalizations and definitely found
the vocal imprint of the starling on
this piece of
mozart's that has for so long been um
despised by musicians everywhere because
it makes them sound so discordant and
like they don't know what they're
doing but it seems like mozart knew
exactly what he was doing he was
composing a kind of
musical analogy for his bird anyway
other than this couple of exceptions
carmen unfortunately has little interest
in mozart but she
loves bach and she loves bluegrass
and she was fortunate with bach because
claire my daughter is a fine cellist and
so we had the
um unaccompanied cello suites going on
in the house a lot and carmen would sing
along with them
and my husband happens to be a bluegrass
fan and this is how we discovered
carmen's love of bluegrass
and she even has a favorite band green
sky bluegrass
and i think it's because they have a
really strong mandolin line and the
mandolin lies within you know her
vocal um her natural sort of vocal range
so i tried this out before
um we all gathered here with the
panelists
and it seemed a little bit loud and
distorted
but i'm going to give it a try because i
will tell you that it also sounds kind
of loud and distorted from our home
we'll have
bluegrass playing and then carmen will
be singing along
so if you want to ask you know
why i what i mean when i
disbelieve the sense that only humans
can be engaged with music
i will show you that what it looks like
when carmen
is engaged with music
[Music]
so i hope that worked where's my
don't worry i won't make you listen to
that anymore i hope you could get a
sense of that
so um oh wow i do really have
starling hair all right
what i love when i listen to carmen
engaging with music
is thinking about her interaction
or um mozart's bird's interaction
with his family and i actually believe
his startling to
be male so even though i said that males
and females
are both really gifted mimics a
just really sing the males are have a
little bit of an edge on that
it seems that females might be able to
um apprehend complexity
in sound and vocalizations better than
male starlings can
but males can mimic a little bit better
than females and so because
mozart's bird was such a gifted mimic
and could
uh mimic part of this concerto i believe
him to be a male and plus it was easier
for me to write to have a male styling
and females darling
so i love thinking of mozart with his
darling in his home
um this is before he was married um
mozart with his sister nanural
that's his mother ana maria in the back
who has passed and
and this is getting long so i'm going to
just say a couple couple more things
anna maria
died when mozart was 21
in paris and
leopold died
while mozart had his starling and he
lived in vienna
while leopold was living in salzburg um
leopold died in 1787 he was 62 years old
which was a pretty good age
for the time and at the time mozart
didn't
attend the funeral and much was made of
this
and it still is by biographers that it
shows that
you know leopold was very kind of
authoritarian and controlling and
officious
with mozart which he was but there was
also when you read their letters just so
much love between them
at the time that leopold died mozart
had young children in the house
constanza
was sick with a septic leg and their
financial situation was terrible
and by the standards of the day a
funeral was very expensive so if
mozart went and created a memorial
service for his father in salzburg
remember 250 miles away
um he would have had to lay out for the
expenses of the funeral and even higher
mourners which is something they did at
the time
so it wasn't that mozart didn't go or
didn't want to go
to leopold's funeral in my opinion it's
that he simply could not go
but two months after um leopold died
starling died and from his garden
in vienna mozart created a
a
grand and formal funeral so
he buried the bird in the garden he
invited friends to wear
formal morning clothes and play music
and he even wrote an elegy for the bird
and when people talk about this
this contrast and mozart not attending
his father's funeral and then creating
this formal funeral for his bird
most people most biographers don't
mention it again but those that do
posit two different theories one is that
it was simply a joke
that it it you know it was over the top
mozart was
you know always a prankster and it would
appeal to his sense of humor too
uh to create a formal funeral for a bird
and the other is that it was you know a
way of grieving his father
that this is a little bit of pop
psychoanalysis that people are doing
that sort of the vessel of the funeral
um in any form offered a channel for the
grief that he wasn't
able to offer in person to his father
and i honestly believe that both of
those
things make sense certainly a bird
funeral would play
to mozart's wonderful sense of the
absurd but
um and having a funeral
could be a container for history but
there's a third option
that biographers never mention but that
anyone
living with a sterling could not help
but realize
and that is that it was just sincere
mozart loved his darling here was a bird
that like him
was uh a good mimic
musical mischievous intelligent
and friendly and he lost this bird
during a time
when he was in financial distress
he lost a child he lost his father
he was working very hard at the time his
dad died he was writing don giovanni
and here is this musical cheerful
presence with him
during all of this it was a sincere loss
for him
and he wrote an elegy and i'm going to
read it to you
because it's wonderful this is marcia
davenport's
[Music]
1932 translation
a little fool lies here whom i held dear
a starling in the prime of his brief
time
whose doom it was to drain death's
bitter pain
thinking of this my heart is riven apart
a reader shed a tear and you also hear
he was not naughty quite which is a line
i love so that's what i think of carmen
she's not naughty
but gay and bright and under all his
brag a foolish wag
this no one can gain say and i will lay
that he is now on high
and from the sky praises me without pay
in his
friendly way yet unaware that death
has choked his breath and thoughtless of
the one
whose rhyme is thus well done
i visited mozart's grave no one knows
exactly where he's buried
but um because it's getting late i think
i'm just gonna
kind of move on this is his grave in
vienna it's at this beautiful
tangled ancient kind of
haunted cemetery outside of town
and there used to be a really big
memorial there out of granite with
sort of the muse and contemplation and
they took that memorial
in the late 1800s and they moved it to
the new
vienna municipal city cemetery
other side of town and so all kinds of
mozart pilgrims go and they think that
big memorial
that they were sort of created to be
this garden of dead musicians
um schumann is buried there salieri
beethoven and then they added this
memorial statue of mozart you have to
read the fine print to find out that
mozart's actually there
um not there but in the actual graveyard
where he is
um he was buried in a common grave which
was the practice of the time
and so they didn't put grave markers in
the exact place and so this is in the
approximate place
and when i was there you can't really
tell that jungley tingle
um the sense of oldness and the
hauntedness that enchants
the cemetery but one of the things that
really struck me was i kind of leaned
down and looked up at this chair
and i expected him to be you know
contemplating some sort of you know the
music of the spears
and a sense of the spirit of mozart but
all i really got was this look of
oh my gosh i'm here forever and
he's not even buried here just made me
laugh
there are now 200 million starlings
in north america and ecologically
they are you know somewhat disastrous
in certain ways but individually
they have these bright minds these
shining
feathers this lovely unique
consciousness
that is so instructive you know i think
it makes us aware when we walk in the
world
that we are so deeply interconnected
to um the
all of the kindred
of all of the more than human world
um
and so i'm going to just finish with one
little
sentence from the book and now let us
keep watching this murmuration
we can talk about how murmurations work
in the q a if you all want to
so it is in reciprocity to this idea of
wonder
and complexity that we discover what
draws
us and along with it our originality
our creativity our soulness our gladness
our art mozart found inspiration
in the presence of a common bird for us
too
the song of the world so often rises in
places
we had not thought to look
so i'm going to end with mozart and the
starling there
for the moment i'll try to invite carmen
back i've got her favorite applesauce
we'll try to draw her over
but i'm going to just briefly say
and i apologize for this but
i have a book coming out next week and i
am basically under contractual
obligation to mention it whenever i can
uh
my publicist wanted something of me this
afternoon and i said i can't i
you know i can't deal with that i'm
preparing for this lecture and she said
well make sure you mention your book and
i'm slightly frightened of her
so i'm mentioning my book rooted life at
the crossroads of science nature and
spirit
is available next week i hope that
you'll
stay in touch that's my personal um
oh my first i thought i had my email
address on there
it's just landed help gmail.com please
feel free to contact me
and follow along on any of the
um socials all right i'd be delighted to
stay in touch
so i'm going to pop off the stop share
screen
oh great thank you very much what a
lovely time i'll say that
um i just want to say thank you i i know
this is a really platform
i'm a really conversational um speaker
so
right now right now it's the fun part
because from here on in it's gonna be
it's gonna be real easy
uh the vast majority of your videos and
sounds
were were perfectly fine so especially
with
some of the videos that were that were
challenging before so
uh yeah i i just want to reflect that i
think um
anyone who has experienced uh a a bird
as a pet or a domesticated bird
understands the kind of uh way that
uh it connects people to the
the intelligence of birds the person
personality of birds in a unique way
that
and uh so i think you're you're exactly
right this uh the
avian intelligences uh plural
is a big part and and i don't think
anybody who also had a pet
or could um could doubt
that um mozart was sincere
and not joking in his uh celebration of
the life of his pet starlight that was
uh
so we have lots of comments in the and
questions in the in the uh
and i just remind for those of you who
raise your hand if you can put your
questions
in the chat then that will help us and i
think i'll just start
with some of the questions i've been
reviewing it and uh
lyanda if you want us field or if you
need any any
if you have any i want to have a
conversation about any of these i'd be
glad to help out so the first comes from
jane
mccall pallidi who has uh do starlings
pass on their
linguistic abilities to their to their
offspring to their children
right well pass on is an interesting you
know phrase so they
it it it's unlikely that they pass it on
genetically but they do teach their
offspring some of their unique
phrases so starlings have a lot of
complex vocalizations that
people hearing them think that they're
it's just wild craziness but when you
study them you find that there's an
order to it but part of that order is in
every starling song it starts with a
whistle and then moves on to
there's this little you know some of
some long whistles and a crescendo and
some rattles
there's a section for personal
repertoire
so they will throw in sounds that they
favor
that they've learned that they've
mimicked themselves and that varies from
individual to individual
but we do find that in family groups
males and female
partners mates will start picking up
and mimicking back to one another each
individual's
own mimic sounds and then the young will
also pick up on the
uh unique individual repertoires of the
parents that said the young will go on
and
create their own repertoire and choose
their own mimic sounds to add in
so um there's a lot of sharing and
learning
but it doesn't seem to be genetically
passed on
yeah yeah great and so uh a question
from susan uh honest
uh do how do starlings compare to the
liar birds uh as mimics
oh nothing compares to the liar versus
um we've all seen the david attenborough
footage of the life of the liar bird
doing the you know the rewind of the
camera
and um i personally feel that starlings
although they can they are so gifted and
they can pick up so much
and they can learn songs and it's
incredibly impressive there's always a
whistly
birdiness to it and the things that
uh carmen and other starlings mimic that
sound when i say it's pitch perfect and
we can't tell them apart
that's something like oh the beep of a
microwave so that is a very kind of
burdish sound
anyway but otherwise there's a whistly
birdiness to it that in the lyre bird
somehow they are they're on another
plane
so birds um you know humans have larynx
as birds have psyrixes and so there's a
lot of variation
in the vocal cords and the vocal
apparatus that allow different species
to have different um capacities and the
lyrebird
is like the grain
feel free to i mean the closest
relatives to
the starlings which about 120 species
total are
the new world mockingbirds and their
relatives so so the capacity for mimicry
evolutionarily goes quite far back in
this history but not all starlings do it
and the other way to think about it is
that starlings have more of their own
stuff to say uh so mimicry is a smaller
compart
of their repertoire because they they
have uh starling stuff to do
and that's less true of flyover who is
uh mostly composing its repertoire from
other species so
yeah that's really interesting yeah
starlings have a really high plasticity
of behavior so
they have a lot going on yeah okay so a
a question from bruce
mcintyre do birds have perfect pitch
what do you think i don't know i i don't
know
i mean starlings i i do you know the
answer to that
well i i would say i don't think they
have names for pitches
so they're not going to say oh that's a
that's a c sharp uh but obviously
um in order to learn from con specifics
they do have to
uh uh match on on frequency and what's
also interesting of course is that they
have the
individual motivation to do uh perhaps
innovate so they don't do it slavishly
but they
but they uh they clearly have that
capacity i think
right when you hear young birds learning
especially males in the fall sometimes
they'll already start learning
their their uh their song their
their adult song and they're very
imperfect so we can hear them working to
get it right
and i hear that with carmen when she's
learning to mimic she's
her current project is the buick's
friend who's singing outside
in the camellia outside of her window
and she she practices
she gets it wrong and wrong and then she
eventually gets it right
so that's social learning right
one of my advisors brought pain
published a paper that a local
um a local house finch had learned from
a canary
that uh one of the neighbors put out on
her porch
uh so that the bird could sing that spot
so even it goes even from domestication
into the wild not just
the other way a question from susan
is is carmen a female and does she lay
on fertilized eggs
okay carmen is a female and it's really
hard to tell you know unless you've done
a lot of startling watching
there's not a lot of dimorphism between
the feathers of the males and females
but in the breeding season especially
the males have these sort of punky
feathers on their wings and their nut
feathers are extra plumy
and uh oh there's a cat on the loose i
finally
remembered to put the kitten away this
cat is very fat though
give me one second i'm just going to
lock this
that is just that has been such a
fascinating talk oh my god
so rick do you want any tragedy
leander rick i cannot resist uh chiming
in here
so does carmen have her personal song
yeah so you know okay so what carmen
does
is and this is really interesting
because
a lot of passer and birds have
vocalizations that are
innate if you if you get them when
they're young like i did carmen and they
she's she wasn't really exposed to
carmen's sons and yet she sings
the full range of of
the typical female song so it starts
with a whistle a whistle
and then her own repertoire of sounds
and then
um another kind of rapidly sounding in
this crescendo whistle at the end
and males will add in this rattling song
thing so
it goes there's there's just a a
formula for starling songs and she sings
it but she definitely has
her own repertoire of mimicked sounds
and she will integrate that
into the typical starling um pattern
it's fascinating i hope that is is that
your question
yeah that was my question um and i guess
i
would be great rick and this does the
signature song
change with age well as uh
lyanda pointed out most of the these
birds that learn their songs um
learn or basically hit the target within
the end of the first year the first
spring or the second year
and then stay that the single song or
the entire repertoire
unchanged there are however some birds
that are much more open-ended and
mimicry is a great way to get open-ended
that's probably why mimicry evolved at
all because
uh there was either social choice or
made choice for
a very open or extreme repertoire and if
you keep
learning other songs you can rep a car
keeps growing right
it's more uh innovative and and novel
um but uh another bird that learns their
song
uh continuously throughout life is a
canary which is the
wild species that the domestic canary
came from so
canaries learned their song renewed
every spring they have at wild ones have
a have a have a new
uh rush of song innovation and learning
well it from there no to bomb back in
the 90s
i found out that that was actually
associated with the origin of new
neurons in the brain
in bond control areas which was part of
the discovery uh that vertebrate brains
can
grow new neurons which prior to that is
not understood but that
that fundamental uh biological fact
which is now
underlies you know treatment for stroke
and neurodegenerative disorders in
humans
was discovered in birdsong with exactly
the question of mind
and lyanna's uh just a quick final
comment
slash question it might be crazy but
lyanna do
you hear emotion when she improvises
oh i know not a fair question
and you know it's deeply possible right
you
um i i don't know about emotion i mean i
i think that she
is definitely um
she gets more excited when she hears
certain music compared to other
music and i personally i have to say i'm
not against
it you know they're in science there's
this whole oh my gosh we don't want to
anthropomorphize
and i actually think you know along you
know 160 years ago darwin
himself said that um he didn't
in positing natural selection as a
mechanism
for evolution he didn't see any
difference in
position of morphological
uh and consciousness felt like
didn't think it made any sense that
there was a morphological continuation
but
consciousness somehow stopped with
humans and he readily called animals
peaceable
calm happy whatever so um and i think
that we've
really really restricted the ways that
we understand different intelligences
by not allowing ourselves to just
acknowledge that sometimes we recognize
when an animal is in pain or is in
distress or
agitated um at the same time we don't
want to over attribute
so when you say emotions i pause for a
minute but i do think that there are
times when
she's engaged when she's satisfied when
she's
not agitated um and a lot of that has to
do with what's going on early
thank you amanda if i may we have a
great question
from professor brown who's president of
the mozart society of america
he says the l at the end of stall uh
sick as it was called in that initial
note on the purchase and the ledger
makes it a diminutive the german do you
imagine that it was a
baby a chick starling when oats are
purchased star
um you know i mean i can
look into it further but as i understand
it that was
a um
a that was one of the german common
names
for starling vogelstar
and it meant little star because and
it's one of the reasons that we call
starling starlings and their common name
and um it's they they fly they they have
pointed wings pointed tails pointed
noses and they look like little stars
when they're in flight and that's one
theory of where the common name came
from
and so um it might have just been little
star rather than baby starling
and mozart was a decent naturalist
he knew something about or he was
interested in the natural world
and he certainly knew the common species
name for the bird
and so later biographers reading that
note would think that
thought that he named the bird star
based on that note
but he was really just labeling it
according to the common name so
um to answer the question though
it's unlikely that it was a baby because
one of the things that
caused mozart or urged mozart to
purchase this particular bird was that
it was singing the
um motif from the concerto and birds
even gifted mimics like starlings are
not able to
mimic that something complex until
they're several years old
and i are rather several months old and
for many reasons given the time of year
it was may and so starlings are
young in may are born in may even in um
in now austria where mozart was
and so it could not have been a baby it
would have had to be about a year old at
that time to be seeking
at that level of complexity so my
conjecture is that it's a year old bird
and he died when um three years later so
at about four years
of age great question
and indeed in august 1784 emperor joseph
ii decreed
new burial regulations in vienna for
sanitation reasons
which later led to mozart's anonymous uh
shroud burial in 1791
by burying his dear star the composer
was probably
breaking a law and that's thanks to
mcintyre
great contribution yeah
it's true people feel that mozart was
there's this myth that mozart was buried
in a popper's grave and
no one attended his funeral and it's
seen as this view that he was sort of
spat upon by the city to which he gave
so much
but as um the commenter says it's just
it was new regulations by joseph ii and
of uh for sanitation and for frugality
there was so much excess in the funeral
um
processions before that and these were
changes that mozart agreed with
so um yeah he was buried in a grave with
about 10 other people they shroud throw
some lie on top
and then in 10 years time they would
reuse that plot for other people
we had a participant ask about the
participatory mode i think you were
mentioning
do you remember that part of your talk
and
could you go over that again please okay
so what i was really saying is that um
what i initially thought in terms of
carmen's mimicry
was participating in the household that
she was just picking up
environmental sounds and i'm going to be
i'm going to
tell you that this is going to reflect
poorly upon me but
the first environmental sound that she
learned she could say hi
and hi honey and khmer but i heard her
making the sound that went
i thought what is that sound and i
finally figured out one day
that it's the vacuum on the wine you
know
you know how you you have this vacuum
that vacuums out the extra air
so her first mimicked environmental
sound was you know
associated with me hitting the bottles
not really hitting the bottle just
sipping the chardonnay but anyway
um i kind of thought that for a long
time that she was just
learning household sounds but what
turned out to be the actual case
was that although she was learning to
mimic
household sounds she wasn't just doing
them along with us
she was doing them in anticipation
of the sound that she knew was going to
happen next
and that is the fascination of
the
just the complexity of the mindscape of
this bird that
that she introduced to me i mean when i
uh brought
starman carmen into the home as part of
research for
creating this book i kind of thought i
knew what was gonna happen you know she
was gonna
she was gonna mimic a lot and that was
gonna be interesting she might learn the
starling
or the mozart motif and that would be
great um but instead
she just really upended my sense of the
possibilities of the infinity of
intelligences that
uh surround us in the beyond human world
so that idea of and this is is little
understood
in the literature a little researched in
the literature because
it's something that you can't figure out
just hanging out with a bird in a lab
but it just takes months of sort of
living day in and day out
to finally figure out the pattern that
she's not just singing along
or not just singing your favorite songs
she's listening to you
open the microwave door and then before
the beeps come
she's making the beeps she's
anticipating what's going to happen next
she's just there waiting to say i'm here
i know what's going to happen and here
it is
it's wonderful
one of the last questions does carmen
communicate intelligently with other
species so we know you have cats
for instance does she talk with the cat
to the cat at the cat
well she mimics the cat so she
when she sees the cat she does meow
because she knows the cat's gonna meow
and as i said she has this anticipatory
a relationship with life but um
one of the reasons that she's not
releasable to the wild in addition to
not knowing how to fend
for herself and not knowing the uh
complicated star
starling social networks is that she
thinks cats are her friends
so i don't let the cats out when carmen
is flying around just because sometimes
you can see the instinct coming over
them and they're just the arms they know
they're not supposed to kill stuff that
lives in the house
but sometimes the instinct is just you
know one of these days it it
would go arrive so the thing that does
happen though
is when one of the cats goes to the
aviary and sits on it's the aviary goes
from the ceiling all the way to the
floor
and the cat will go up to the wire put
their noses right up to the wire and
carmen will come and put her bill
right next to their nose right next to
it
and they'll maybe swat at her and she
just jumps back about
two inches and then so
so they socialize together i mean i
think the cats just want to kill her
but carmen thinks something is visiting
me
whenever anyone goes to carmen's aviary
she just comes right up to see them
and looks right into their eyes and
tilts their head and she does that with
the cats as well
and she might perceive that she's safe
thanks to the aviary enclosure
she does but i i don't know what would
happen if she
yeah i don't trust her to know better
thank you um let's see other
other questions did i miss any
we had people asking uh can you purchase
an adult starling
uh as mozart did no and someone else
already said it would be illegal
is that because they're non-native so
it's actually interesting i mean i
i do not recommend having a starlings
pet they're very very high maintenance
takes a lot of work but it is also
illegal
in some states you are able to get a
license to happen as a pet
when i talk to our own washington state
fish and wildlife
person um and asked why why
we are allowed to you know with impunity
kill adult starlings you know without
without telling anyone it's fine it's
legal it's even encouraged
um why can we not just have one in the
house
and he said that he's they are worried
about people propagating them as pets
and it's kind of a silly worry because
there are so many starlings and
you know we kill lots of stones we kill
the you know
millions of starlings a year um for
agricultural
um protection but
it doesn't make a dent in the starling
population and so someone would have to
release a heck of a lot of starlings in
order for it to make any difference
and it's hard to imagine what the motive
for doing that would be so
i'm not saying that i think it's a good
idea for people to have
pet starlings but i don't think it makes
sense for us to be able to
you know kill them or whatever and but
not keep them as pets but there is no
you know legal starling trade out there
yeah
you'll have to you're on your own you're
gonna get a startling
i thought it was especially interesting
uh in your book
how you you delved into the rather
brutal ways in which
uh it's open season on starlings uh
and and the various i remember some of
the
harrowing stories you told of people uh
doing their
their bit i suppose to protect native
species by by killing off the starlings
and yet
one of the things i really gathered from
from your talk in your book
was how doing so and uh such a focus
on eradicating them inures
us to their own uh special nature
and this greater intelligence that we
can gather
and immerse ourselves in and with of of
these animals that are otherwise
unwelcome here they did come here at our
own hand
it was someone who brought them over the
releasing them in the park the
shakespearean
story and i it taught me to look for
instance at the house sparrows outside
nesting
you know they they have a beauty and a
rhythm of their own life and it's
that has value too so thank you for that
right i mean one of the things is
it's not either or you know one of the
things that's
beautiful about the complexity of human
intelligence is that we can hold both of
these things at one time
we can dislike starlings ecologically we
can understand that their presence is an
ecological harm
and yet we can be inspired or
um by the interconnection that their
consciousness invites
and and just by their even just by their
beauty
so it's it's it's not one or the other
it's
we can we can do all of these things at
once and that's one of the things i
tried to do
with this research was invite that kind
of nuance
great um i guess rick do you have any
closing questions of your own
no i i i joined this thoroughly and uh
i'm uh i'm fascinated to see this new
angle on understanding uh
uh bird intelligence and also the
history of others who have
appreciated it as well so thank you very
much
um yeah so at this point i want to say a
big thank you
to leonda and to rick for this wonderful
wonderful event and
we are wishing you the best for your new
book and uh
i can't wait to read that too and
continue to have fun with carmen it was
so nice and generous of you to share
share her sort of uh flying around and
um
and i'm glad she decided to participate
in today's session
i want to thank everyone thank you for
bearing with the
technological rockiness and also just
the sort of
you know awkwardness of the talking head
way that this pla platform requires us
to
communicate but the the q a is always
the most fun
and um i'm just delighted to be part of
the series again i want to thank
everyone so much for having me
and for listening and professor rick
thank you
you're a delight i'm a fan of your work
and
it was so fun to be here with you yeah
uh so thank you everyone for attending
and talk to uh thank you so much tai
and guy for helping making it all go
very smoothly
so bye everyone